wall street
pas de bol
pourquoi l'avocat
oui le cas
c'est une grâce parce
smile vols de gol dix ans dix ans que je
voyage à travers le monde en sac à dos
et à l'intérieur donc pas un
dictionnaire mais deux boules un foulard
est un jeu de cartes alors la magie
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire n'est pas un truc mais une
émotion
elle m'a permis de me construire elle
m'a permis aussi d'aller à la rencontre
de véritables héros septembre 2005
je vis ma première fusillade au mexique
et je décide de quitter la capitale pour
aller dans le sud du pays d donc je me
dirige vers la première station de bus
pour quitter le district fédéral
et quand j'arrive à la station de bus
elle est fermée et un homme est à
l'entrée un sdf un homme maigre salle
avec un pantalon déchiré en deux et
juste plusieurs noeuds pour cacher ses
parties génitales
je décide demain soir à côté de cet
homme au moment je m'assois elle me dit
attends je vais chercher quelque chose
chez moi je reste un peu surpris parce
que chez lui c'était bien la station de
bus est en fait il va derrière la
station et me rapporte un petit bout de
carton pour que je puisse m'asseoir et
éviter de me salir alors j'ai fait
quelques tours de magie pour créer un
lien entre lui et moi est très
rapidement il ya une complicité qui
s'installe et au bout de quelques heures
happy que paris devant nous ce gars un
homme sort et c'est de regarder lors du
premier départ il avait des difficultés
donc je me lève je lui donne lors du
premier départ et pour me remercier cet
homme me donne pièce de 10 pesos et
qu'est ce que je fais bien entendu avec
la pièce de 10 pesos je la donne à cet
homme cette sdf et au moment où je lui
tends la pièce ils la refusent
elle me dit non garde là j'en ai pas
besoin
je comprends pas je lui demande de
m'expliquer il me dit tu sais moi je
n'ai rien je n'ai pas de famille je vis
dans la misère mais je me sens bien
par contre toi
tu as une certaine zone de confort tu
vis avec une certaine richesse alors
regarde voilà parce que tu en auras
beaucoup plus besoin que moi
cette pièce là voici et elle par un
partage dorénavant tous mes voyages
juillet 2009
je décide de partir au népal pour faire
un trek toujours avec le même sac à dos
les mêmes bull le même foulard elle les
mêmes jeux de cartes et entre les
paliers d'altitude que je ne respecte
pas et les sangsues je perd connaissance
en pleine montagne et je me réveille
chez d'un sherpa
je sais pas où je suis la seule chose
qu'il me dise est qu un monastère
tibétain se trouve à deux kilomètres de
là donc je me dirige là bas sans savoir
pourquoi
et à quelques mètres de ce monastère je
vois des enfants courir vers moi en toge
et à ce moment là j'ai ressenti un grand
moment de solitude
alors juste pour vous dire j'ai eu 2 ou
bac en anglais donc mon niveau d'anglais
est très faible et la seule chose que
j'ai pu dire est que j'ai pu faire c'est
de sortir une boule lui demander de la
toucher et donc je m'étais la boule dans
sa main je comptais jusque 3 et a3 la
boule disparaissait et réapparaissez
dans l'autre ment à ce moment là les
enfants commencent à applaudir et souris
et il appelle les moines du monastère à
venir vers moi et à refaire la deuxième
fois une deuxième fois le même tour
alors j'ai pas si vous le savez mais un
tour de magie
c'est comme une blague on répète jamais
deux fois et là j'avais pas le choix
donc les moines sont arrivés vers moi et
j'ai refait la même chose mais cette
fois-ci de façon différente
je gardais la boule dans la main la
deuxième je la donne et aux moines et au
compte de 3 la boule voyager d'une main
à l'autre
et à ce moment là tous les mois des les
enfants y en a qui ont crié ma qu'on
commence à applaudir de troncs sourit il
y en a un qui montraient aucune émotion
c'est celui qui avait les deux boules
dans la main la seule chose qu'il a pu
montrer ce sont les larmes qui ont coulé
sur ses joues alors suite a à cet effet
magique et - invité à rencontrer le lama
qui étaient présents ce jour-là au
monastère et donc j'ai partagé quelques
heures quelques jours voire quelques
semaines avec eux parce que ça m'a valu
une amende pour expiration de visa à
katmandou et à ce moment là j'ai
ressenti la même chose qu'avec le sdf au
mexique
c'est à dire cette sensation d'avoir
très peu de choses très peu de confort
et pourtant de se sentir véritablement
heureux lorsque je voudrais pas dire
c'est que je suis parti ce n'est pas la
cause d'une déception amoureuse et que
ces moines m'avait appris à être heureux
tout seul à mai mais pour pouvoir aimer
les autres et ce sont pour moi de
véritables héros voilà ce sont des gens
qui agissent sur votre conscience sur
votre réflexion de vie et qui la
bouleversent à tout jamais alors si vous
tapez sur google
ayrault vous tomberez jamais sur ces
personnes là ni sur les moines ni sur
les sdf vous allez tomber sur des super
héros avec des supers nanas et des super
pouvoirs et suite à ce voyage j'ai
rencontré des personnes incroyables
inestimable au brésil sur les îles en
inde et elles avaient toutes un point
commun
c'était qu'elle arrivait à communiquer
une émotion sans même comprendre la
langue sans parler un seul mot c'est ce
que j'appelle le savoir émotionnel
vous n'avez pas besoin d'aller à l'autre
bout de la plaine pour le trouver ça
fait neuf ans maintenant devant je fais
de la magie à l'hôpital dans laquelle on
partage un atelier de magie dans lequel
le patient est acteur de sa propre magie
et dans laquelle pendant ces ateliers en
rééducation fonctionnelle notamment en
collaboration avec l'équipe qui naît on
travaille sur la prade si la littéralité
corporelle
confiance en soi mais surtout une chose
la bonne humeur et comme vous avez face
à vous certaines personnes qui sont
malades et qui arrive à combattre à
lutter pour la vie alors que leur temps
est compté c'est pour moi une des plus
belles choses alors vous savez le
l'hôpital était lui un peu particulier
parce que c'est c'est pour moi un
endroit dans lequel le statut social
n'existe pas et donc vous avez des
personnes ordinaires par contre leurs
actions elles sont extraordinaires et
quand vous avez face à vous une personne
atteinte d'une maladie grave ou vous
êtes face à un enfant en phase terminale
d'un cancer sans cheveux avec un masque
et se trouve de l'autre côté de la vitre
et qu'à côté de vous vous avez sa maman
qui vous demande s'il vous plaît
d'imprimer les photos parce qu'il reste
quelques semaines à vivre
et cet enfant vous voyez dans les yeux
dans son regard qu il en train de
sourire
il vous transmet de l'espoir de
transmettre dernier sourire et parfois
vous donne même de l'espoir sur sa
propre vie alors pour moi c'est tout
simplement les vrais héros et j'ai
ressenti la même chose
la même chose dans les maisons de
retraite dans les ehpad et dans les
unités protégées alzheimer ou maladies
apparentées pour moi en france je trouve
qu'on laisse bien trop souvent la
personne âgée abandonnés oubliés surtout
les personnes alzheimer et pourtant si
on prend le temps d'écouter leurs
histoires de vie on se rend compte
qu'elles ont une vie inestimable et qui
parfois s'apparente à celle du héros
alors j'ai créé il ya deux ans
maintenant un projet d'animation
sensorielle pour les personnes âgées
alzheimer en utilisant la magie ce qui a
permis en fait d'ouvrir un champ
émotionnel et de synchroniser les
émotions c'est à dire qu'avec l'équipe
soignante
on collabore et la magie a démontré que
ça permettait d'éviter par exemple
certains actes de contention d'éviter
les conflits et de diminuer les tensions
entre les résidents pour créer une
dynamique de groupe et je vais vous
raconter l'histoire de gérard voilà son
petit nom cgg
gérard est une personne timide
introverti qui a participé à des
ateliers de ma gym et il était pressé de
montrer ce qu'ils avaient de ce que je
venais d'apprendre c'est à dire la
disparition d'un foulard il va vers
d'autres résidents il fait la
disparition de foulards et gégé a réussi
à surprendre les autres ce qui a créé un
groupe de discussion autour de lui et a
créé un lien très affectif avec une
autre personne est donc gérard a pris
plaisir à partager ce moment avec elle à
tel point que actuellement il est dans
ses tâches quotidiennes il a pris
tellement de plaisir à l'idée qu'ils
aident aussi tous les autres résidents à
l'heure du repas pour découper la viande
servir à boire asseoir les dames
voilà à tel point qu'il a appelé le
président alors toutes ces personnes
n'abdique jamais et dépasse toujours
leurs obstacles pour avancer et elles
passent toutes par les mêmes émotions de
la vie la peur pour ensuite trouver le
courage
arrivé à la persévérance et rencontrer
la joie et le bonheur tout en oubliant
leurs gains et si on me demande un jour
de choisir entre avoir raison ou être
heureux je choisirai toujours la
deuxième option
c'est celle qu'on recherche tous dans
notre vie qui est la plus difficile est
souvent perturbé par notre ego c'est
pour ça que je contredis jamais les
femmes alors nous sommes tous quelque
part un peu héros de notre propre
existence
et souvenez-vous quand je vous ai dit
que la magie n'était pas juste un truc
mais une émotion
en fait c'est bien plus que ça la magie
est magique
elle permet de faire supprimer de faire
tomber les peurs les inhibitions les
barrières entre les langues les cultures
elle permet de créer un lien entre les
êtres est bien plus que ça elle crée
l'émerveillement qui permet parfois
d'offrir à des personnes maladie grave
de façon ponctuelle ou durable une
rémission
alors la magie existe vraiment la magie
de la vie existe vraiment il faut juste
y croire
alors peut-être vol